Hello my name is Lynne Luxton and I am going to have a conversation with
Annamarie Kaplon for the Visible Lives in Oral History Project.
At the New York Public Library. It
is Thursday June the 11th, 2015. And
this is being recorded at the Andrew Heiskell Braille and Talking Book Library
In New York City. Annamarie, thank you for coming. And why don't you
start off and tell us a little something about yourself.
OK thank you for inviting me. My name is Annamarie Kaplon.
I am 58 and a half years old. I'm diagnosed.
From 1987 with retinitis
pigmentosa. Umm, When I was first diagnosed I I thought it
was a very slow progressive blinding disease. I had
My two children at ages thirty two and thirty four. And by forty
I was using a cane so I guess ignorance is bliss.
Because I don't know if I would have had children if, because I thought long slow progressive, I'd be
so I'd be any where between 70 and 80. I started out with a
cane I remember walking one day my children to school and having to get back
alone. And it was so difficult that my first thing to do was to come in
and I called the Helen Keller
School for the Blind, because I was already registered with the Commission. So I said. I'm
going to need
help and they helped me. Within a day or so I had a mobility instructor at the
house which
changed a lot in my world. And she, we, walked for two three weeks at
a time. Canes, subways, buses,
Restaurants, steps, church, wherever I go. And it was a great big
help I think it was
easier for my kids to see that I
was mobile. Mobile. I didn't want them to think
that
life was going to pass me by. And I made a conscious effort
to decide whether I raise my
children or sit back and have someone else do it because I was afraid. and
I didn't want that. So you bite the bullet. And you move on. That's how I felt.
I remember having a conversation with my mother right before I was getting the cane.
And I says to her, you know I'm getting a cane and she says to me
What? You're going to tap your way in the street? I'll help
you and I told her no. I says No, cause you are busy
at the senior center, you go on day trips you go on weekends. I don't want to rely on
you for container of milk or a loaf of bread.
I've gotta do it. My kids get sick. I gotta go to the drugstore. I gotta do what I gotta do.
And that's how I started
saying. Figure it out and go. Well,
years past, of course. You know vision got progressively
worse. All facial recognition was gone. Reading was gone.
Color was gone.
And I went from cain to a seeing eye dog.
Not for any other reason other than I
was walking down the street with two kids. Pocketbook flung over my shoulder. Kid holding
holding one string of the cane. The other kid holding my hand, and I went "boy, do I look like a target."
I said
so I thought the dog would give me a little bit more sense of security. So
I opted to go to a dog. My
first dog was with Freedom Guide.  A yellow lab named
Jedi.
And boy did we travel. He was excellent.  Excellent.
From subway to buses to restaurants. To school. To school trips with the
kids to open house to P.T.A. meetings to working fundraisers at the
kids' school.
But, you know, again, as the kids got older you were less needed to go to these
Places with them. I always thought I needed to be with them but they were.
You know pretty much going "you don't have to come, Mom"  You know...
And that was
another experience in my life to have to go "Hmmm," I
I don't think they need me to go with them anymore. And through all of this of course.
Life changes and my husband passed away when I was forty nine. So now I'm raising for
a fourteen and a sixteen year old.
And I don't. *Phone ringing* "cut" Sorry for the interruption.
umm, I had
a fourteen and sixteen year old. And I just went, "Oh
My God, I've got to do this right." There
was you know, As kids today there was no father figure for a
boy and I was really concerned about that, but my daughter and I were like
so totally on him he didn't have a shot to turn back. He really didn't.
and they did well. They did well. I'm very proud of them. I'm proud of myself
but getting them to the points of being college graduates with masters
and B A's and good jobs and good
people who, um, help people.
I'm very proud of them. You know.? And I have to tell you, sometimes I'm proud of myself. Cool. Good job.
Good job. You know. I then had to get another dog, which is very
traumatic.
Because my Jetty got old and arthritic. And I've got now, as of today,
My black lab named Hobbes. Also from Freedom Guide.
I was also given the opportunity to work at the Helen
Keller School for the Blind. With the
babies from ages I think they go from 1 to 5. On the third floor,
Doing pet therapy. And that has been so great to watch them grow and when
they come back to the school. And you see them and they're like 13 and 14 years old and they'll
look at you and go.
I remember Jedi, I remember you sang...  So good to see
them grow. You look at then and go
wow. How big they got!  And
again the Helen Keller School was my savior. And I speak their praise.
To anybody who would listen to me. They. They helped me. And when
they offered me the position to volunteer.
it was my way of giving back. And I went
great and then of course they got some kind of a grant and they said we could pay you and I said even better.
So what the heck.
And that is been continuing now from one day a week to 2 days a week from
an hour a week to 2 hours a week. So that's where I'm at now. And it's great. And
these babies are so cool. With their little canes and they are going to be so great in
the world and
I don't know what people did years ago they just sat home I don't...I can't even imagine.
I never gave myself the time to feel
sorry for myself. I wouldn't allow that.   It was just me. I
couldn't do my own pity party. I had things to do. I had children
to raise as young, and they had children to take care of. After my husband
died. And you learn different things because when there's a person
with you. He did the bills. He wrote out the checks. I'm going back,
We were not very computer savvy people.
So, you know, it was hard. So I went, oh, I have to
do this. I have to do the income tax. OMG! I don't know how to do income
tax. OK, pack it all up, find an accountant. Worked it out.
Financial aid papers for college. I don't know how to fill those out.
I've never done it. I didn't go to college. Didn't do it. I went OK pack that
up, find someone, go to find an accountant. Bring all your...
Bring all you... there's a way. You just gotta think about it, and
not let it overwhelm you, because blindness is scary. Blindness
is... it it doesn't change who are, it just cramps your
style a little bit. You are who you are. You just go
a little slower. You have to think about it a little bit.
Anything spontaneous. You normally going to bump your head or get burned or something.  So you have to go
little slow.  You have to have a little bit of a plan. You have to know. I mean I have cooked dinner
for
10, 12 people on holidays and whatever. And when they tell that to
people they go. You cook? Yeah, I cook.
The kids have to eat. I have to eat. It's part of life. You eat.  You eat. You eat. OK?
And I would cook for like from Friday to Saturday, let's say, if it was a Sunday holiday.
And then when everybody came over, it would all be hot and cooking in the oven, no heating and whatever, and I would tell
people Look I cook it. I can't serve it with all these people because I'm going to hit somebody in the
head. And I think the more open you are with your blindness and what
you can and cannot do
Makes people understand you a little bit better. You know people are, I think people in
general
are afraid of blind people who are blind. Like, oh my God,
they're blind. Oh my God! How do I talk to them? (?)
People will, sitting in a restaurant, will look at your companion and go
What does she want? (laughs)
Hello? I can speak! You can talk to me.
I don't bite! You're not going to catch it.
You know. It's... I think you
to project that. Because if you come off going "oh, I don't know..."
Let me see, I don't know, can you do that for me?
They'll look at you like, Oh my God, You poor thing.
And I never wanted to be defined as That Poor Thing!
Look at Her!  You know? I wanted to be known as the women that they went...
Oh yeah, she shops, she comes in here, we help her out, she comes with the dog, she gets around,
she goes into the city, she hops on Access-a-Ride, she does what she needs to do.
And I wanted my children to know that. I guess
they were the ones that kept me focused. They kept me going.
I can't break.
Because they got to know to be strong. I don't know if this eye disease passes on to them.
them. I hope it starts and ends with me. I don't know. I don't know down
the road. Children, grandchildren, where this goes.  Don't have a clue.
And I don't think about it because if you think about it you could lose your
mind. And I decided that I needed my children
to say oh mom just doesn't see, but she's good. She's good. If she needs help she'll ask.
she'll ask but most of the time she figures it out. And my children's
friends from when they were young. Just like "Annamarie...
Oh, Annamarie, how you doing? It's me. It's Mary, it's Lauren, it's, it's James.
they weren't afraid. And they grew up with it. and they'll see me on
the street and go hey how you doing Annamarie, it's Allison's friend, blah blah blah blah blah.
You know?  Whereas most people go "Oh,
You don't want me to help you cross that street? No I'm find, but
But if you'd to tell me when the light changes. "Oh you poor thing."
I don't feel like a poor thing.
I don't want to be known as that poor woman who lost her vision.
I want to be known as "Oh look, there's the blind lady with the dog. And I think that's what I am
in the neighborhood. Like people ask me
Are you training that dog? And I go oh no, he's blind and I go
You're blind? And I go Yes. Is that a blind dog? (interviewer laughs)
And I go oh I hope not.
They gave me the wrong dog! And it's like, Oh my God! ??
I think you project who you are. If you're angry
at your situation. People are going to avoid you because you come off bitter
bitter and angry. If you look at the world as a whole picture.
This just cramps your style. Doesn't change anything.
I can't talk about other issues and people who are blinded. Other ailments. I can't even imagine.
But just being blind. You know, you do things a little differently.
But you're up and about and you're
out. OK. I'll tell you a funny story.
When I first got my first seeing eye dog, my
Jetty, you know, the training. You know the training was difficult and of
course it's. it's very intense. And one day I left the house and going to get the
kids at school, they were still in grammar school. And I said to my parents who lived downstairs from
me in the basement. So I'm leaving. I'm going to get the kids from school so
my father goes to me and my mother, "Who you going with?"
I'm with the dog.
And they were all, "You can't go with the dog!"
I said, No I'm going with the dog. They went, "She's going with the dog! What is she doing?. She's going with the...
OK; I'm walking to school and I'm crossing my streets and I'm
doing what I have to do. And my dog Jetty wasn't
acting right
right. I'm like, he keeps to turning around and turning around and
turning
Til I found out later that night.
That my father followed me in his car. (interviewer laughs)
Watching me cross the streets. And Jetty knew my father; knew
the car. And just going, Oh maybe I should get in that car.
So finally that night, I says to him...
Something just wasn't.. didn't feel right. So I says, you know,  I went with the kids and
I went to pick them up and the dog was acting kind of funny and I says to him. Were you in your car?
So now my father who was a very thick-Italian-accented man, went like this...
I'm no know what are you talking about?
(interviewer laughs) I said, were you in the car following me?
And he says to me. This is a free country. He says to me, I can go into my
car anywhere. And go where I want to go. I said, well you're never doing
that again. Because you distracted the dog. You can't do
that. I was trying to cross streets. And he was not concentrating.
Because he was looking at you!
at you. Uh! I can go where I want to go. You're going to tell me where I can
go? Uh! I don't know what you're talking about. I said, Oh, this will never do.
Never ever do. I says so from now on, I said,
I will not tell you people when I'm leaving. If you want to come up to my apartment and not find me there
and get worried, that's up to you. I said, But you can't do that.
I hope you live to be 110 years old, but you're not.
And I gotta go on my own.
Believe me, it is frightening. I walk out of the house every day and
go, Dear Father God, you
must get me where I got to go, and get
home. And when I walk into my door and shut that door, it's like that sigh of relief.
Goes, ah! home base! This is good! Oh, I did it! This is good. And every day.
is the same thing. OK I'm good today. Let me just get there I got to go, Lord,
and get me
back and. That's my way of staying focused.
But the thing with my mom and dad was just hysterical. Just hysterical.
and they, I go no, I'm going with the dog. "She's going with the dog!" How could she go with the dog?
You think we should go with her? Oh no, we won't go with her, we'll just stay. I'm like,
Oh my God, they're losing... they're making me nuts! And you know unfortunately Dad
passed away about 6 years ago. And Mom is, to this date,
99 years old. Alzheimer dementia.
You want them around forever; they're not going to be.
So the only person you can rely on is you. You want your kids to stay
young forever because they'll walk down the street holding your hand saying No, Mom, THIS is
the store.
It's not going to happen. They have got to move on with their lives. And I have had
to allow them to move on with their lives and not feel that
they can't: A,move out of state because they have a blind mother. Oh, never.
never.  Never happen. Or they can't go on vacation because
Mom may need to go somewhere. Oh, no.
Not me. Absolutely not me. that wasn't going to be me. And
I wasn't going to allow them...  Look, I know they're there for me if I need them in a heartbeat.
But they've got to live their lives. Get married, have children and move
on. Stay within the boroughs. I can get on Access-a-Ride, I can get to the boroughs.
You move to another state, uh, I'll figure that out.
it out.You know it just takes a little
time. As for, um, like
special things I do at home. I rubber band things that I want that
I know which is shampoo, which is a conditioner.
My clothes. The devices out there today are fabulous. I don't know what people did back
a hundred years ago.
Everything in my house. Bings and bangs, talks, beeps.
crows the watch, whatever.  You know. Tells me my color, tells me my time.
I'm not as computer savvy as I'd like to be. But I'm
trying.  I'm trying to come into this 21s century.
I get there. I could get an e-mail. I could
forward it and I could do a little searching of the web and download a couple of things but I'm definitely
not like the kids of today. But
again, I got things that read my mail.
It is not easy to be blind. But it's definitely a hell of a
lot easier than it was years ago, where the only thing you
had to do was Braille. And I'm a terrible Braille user. I could do a
basic
A.B.C. Book 2? Uh, I don't know.
know. Maybe one of these days. Maybe it'll be in my bucket list. I don't know.
Um, I have travelled. I've gone to Italy
about 5 years ago with my sister to visit family. And we went to the Italy
Of where my father grew up. And my sister was a great great
vocal tour guide.
She explained. Every nook cranny, cobble-street hill,
The the view of of Naples and the bay and Vesuvius and Capri,
And we'd be standing on like this promenade looking over. And she said to me do you
remember the picture daddy had of Naples?
You know, with the boats in the Mediterranean?  I said Absolutely.
She says
This is the absolute picture. This is it. You can't be more exact,
She says that if you remember that picture this is what we're looking at. And I saw it.
When we went to Pompeii. And we saw the ruins of Pompeii she described it to me.
And there was also I headset that you could have listened to when walking. But there was a feel.
and I got it. and I didn't... I was a little leery about going; I'm going to spend all this money
and I can't see
can't see anything. What I am gonna... but there was a feel. And it was
good and the street where my father grew up on. And the house he grew up
in and... I left the dog home and used my cane
and, you know for, for Europe.  And obviously being blind
is a commodity in Europe. Thing cause every line we got on, they said
They said to us. Come come; signore, veni, veni.  you don't have to wait. Veni! Veni!
I went, whoa!
This is good! I was a commodity!
And my sister goes, I don't have to pay either? They went, no!
They went, no, you're her companion! Oh, OK! So we laughed.
Of course, all of a sudden I came in handy. My cousins wanted to know
know, in Italy, if I could leave them a cane. So when they wanted to come in
some place, they would just pretend they were blind, and I went, no.
And went, no, no, no, they went OK. And it
just a wonderful experience. Wonderful to just
be there and just.... I've never been to Europe before so this was a
a chance of a lifetime
experience. I have traveled on cruises with friends.
Um, Vegas, uh, Washington.
And I have met more kind
people. Again, I haven't traveled alone. I'm not... I'm...I'm brave but I'm not THAT brave.
There are more people willing to help than not. When you get to a hotel and someone walks you in,
they'll get you up and take you to your rooms. You want to come out and go to the desk,
there's more than enough
hands. But again. I also think that that's when
you project yourself as someone who
is nice.  You don't think you're entitled.
And I think that people sometimes who are blind think they have a sense of entitlement.
And they're angry. And they project that. And I think when
I see that in some blind people that bothers me. That bothers...they're angry.
They're angry. They have a right to be angry. I get angry I get
But I don't let
it eat me. You
just can't. You die. If you expel this kind of... If I expel
If I expel this much energy trying to be this
angry, I can't do it. But that's me. That's me. So
I think when you come off and you ask people and you're kind. Instead of standing on the corner
going WHO'S GOING TO HELP ME CROSS THIS STREET?
Not me! If I was... If you had vision, would you do? I wouldn't do it.
But if you stand there and go "excuse me, can someone just let me know if I have the light?"
There are more kind people than not in this world. And
so what's going to be 20 years from now?
Who knows? A new dog?
Some grandchildren maybe? If I ever get so lucky. I'm going to be the oldest grandma
grandma in history. Um, A little more traveling maybe with friends
and family.
family. And I guess my goal right now is to just see my kids settled
in nice relationships, I'd like that, or anything that makes them happy. Because you know.
With kids what you want and what they want are
always two different things. As long as they're
So I'm done. That's me. That's great! Is that okay?
Is that OK? That is wonderful. Is... are there
any kinds of things that you would like to say that in the future
future when people listen to you and listen to this, that you think are really important?
You've spoken eloquently. Thank you. About how important it is to
be yourself. And
And to project a positive image. Is there anything else that...
In the future... let me think
OK.
OK you can turn it on. I'll think of something. Yes.
You know. There is so much going
on in technology today
that. I don't know if blindness will, I don't know, maybe a hundred years
maybe 100 years from now is not something they can't possibly cure.
They probably can't. Anything artificial, anything
Computerized in the chip. And you've got to have some kind of
hope to hold onto. The only thing I can tell people who are going through the beginnings
of visual impairment and vision loss.
Seek help.
Go to the professionals. This is not something you can deal with on
your own whether you go to Helen Keller, whether you go to the Jewish
Guild, whether you go to the library. Whether you go to Visions. Whatever is out there in
your community.
You must get the help you
need to be who you are. Because if you go like this: "I'm
never leaving my house."  You're not going to be... you can't do that. There are people out
there who will help you. See the doctors that are out there. New devices.
New things are coming out every day. Maybe not in your case, maybe not
in your lifetime.
But they'll fix it.
That's my thought. My thought is that they're going to fix these eyes one of these days. Maybe
not for me. That's OK.
But if they need me to try different things out, I'm more
than willing to go get, take the shot.
I would experiment. I think.  Depending on how invasive it is.
I would try different techniques. I would try different technology,
equipment. I was asked to do it.
tryout for something that's coming out of
Israel. Um, it was a great little device. I think they're on
the right track. I think it needs more work. And I sat with
these scientists for, um, a couple hours one day about a year ago. It
was great.
It's... but it wasn't going to give me what I needed
On the outside. It was only going to help me fit in my home. I didn't need help in my home. I know my home.
But you've gotta... anyone who was going blind, or has anything in their family.
They must get professional advice. And they must seek out the people who can help
them retrain their whole
lifestyle. Terrific.  Thank you. Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you.